one of the things we've not covered that
is such a critical part of communication
and maybe more importantly even what you
say is your ability to listen to people
it's a huge part of communication you
know i've taught you before that people
don't respond to what they hear
or see they respond to how they feel
when they interact with you and one of
the best ways to make somebody feel good
is that they feel listened to and that
they feel heard let's talk about some
critical steps of being a great listener
you know there's this thing that's out
there too that says hey when you're
speaking to a woman she doesn't want you
to solve her problem she just wants you
to listen to her you've all heard this
before right man that's different let me
tell you none of this stuff is gender
specific it's not true at all
nobody wants you to solve their problem
necessarily not right away everybody
wants to be heard everybody wants to be
listened to everybody likes to talk
about themselves and so just please
remember that this is not gender
specific men and women aren't different
on this men like to be heard as well men
like to be important men like to be
funny men like to be interesting
men want to share their ideas and
thoughts and worries and fears with
other people just like women do so
remember this you don't always want to
just go solve their problem right away
next thing is this
always be asking people for
understanding so that when they say
something when they're finished speaking
ask them so what i think you're saying
is or what i'm hearing is or clarify
this for me because this shows how
deeply you were listening when you ask
for clarification and what i'm hearing
is by the way when you say the sense of
somebody so what i'm hearing is
that lets them know you were hearing
them that you were listening to them so
as i was listening to you this is what i
understood help me understand clarify
for me because this gives a deeper sense
you were listening to somebody the next
thing is what i'm doing right now with
you make eye contact look right at them
when you're talking to them don't be
distracted don't look around don't look
at your phone the way you tell me i'm
important is by looking at me i have a
significant person in my life and one of
the things that drives me crazy is i'm
always saying are you listening to me
and she's always like yes of course i'm
listening to you and i'm like well could
you look at me and let me know
you're listening to me i'm not going to
say who that is either but we all have
that person in our life who they're
listening but they don't know to let us
know they're listening one of the best
ways you can do that is by just looking
right at somebody
nodding with them when they say
something you agree with right smiling
when it's funny like giving a normal
response you'd say well this is basic
stuff you'd be surprised how often you
look away how often you're not focused
the next thing is check your body
language are you leaning in are you
welcoming are you warm or are your arms
crossed when you're talking to somebody
see i have this tendency when i'm really
listening i get really drawn in one of
the things i do is i get very serious
and i almost begin to grimace and make a
face because i'm so interested i'm in
deep thought
but what happens is my visual on my face
doesn't indicate to them that i'm
enjoying what they're saying or that i'm
listening very deeply so make sure that
your facial expression this may seem
basic but your facial expression
matches the moment
matches the emotion some other people do
something different they're always
smiling
when something very serious is being
said that's not an appropriate facial
expression and it looks like you're not
listening or it disconnects the
connection if you will
no pun intended between you and that
person so check your facial expressions
make sure you're looking at them check
your physiology and your body language
the next thing is that when someone's
talking the highest form of listening is
to let them finish their sentence do not
interrupt them do not interrupt them i
do this all the time when i get excited
oh really almost like i want to jump in
and get my point in before they're
finished or i want to sound smarter or
if i don't say it now i'm going to
forget to say it probably the number one
weakness in my ability in listening to
people is my desire and tendency to jump
in before they finish their thought and
what that says is my thoughts more
important than yours my needs are more
important than you i'm done listening to
what you're saying be careful to say
things like this when they're talking
uh-huh right got it yeah wow
because what that does is it's called a
nudge
you're nudging them along verbally to
finish it's like hurry up i got
something to say uh-huh right and that
nudges them verbally i used to think
that those were things i was saying that
confirmed what they were saying but it
was really what was really happening as
i would nudge better is that when
they're done you say wow or that's
interesting or you at least respond when
they're finished all responses are
wonderful once they're finished speaking
but don't do the verbal nudges to get
them to speed up and finish don't finish
sentences for people next it's another
thing i do they'll be saying something
and they'll be struggling for a word and
i give them the word let them find the
word it's their word not yours and
you're stealing control of the
conversation from them and making them
feel like you're not listening to them
don't finish their sentences don't give
them better words don't talk over them
don't interrupt them these are all
things that we all kind of do from time
to time when we get excited
i'm not suggesting if someone is making
an incredible point that you don't begin
to laugh or jump in when it's your
pattern with somebody you're not being a
good listener also use acknowledgement
statements when they're done i agree
that's wonderful that's amazing
congratulations like do things like that
that acknowledge what they said because
when you acknowledge what they said they
feel open that's an invitation to say
more but when you don't acknowledge what
they've said you don't give a statement
to it when they're done then they don't
feel comfortable continuing to speak and
so ask probative questions so when you
ask somebody for example if they're new
to you do you have kids they say yes i
do a follow-up question is what are
their names what are their ages begin to
learn the volley of follow-up questions
the more specific questions you ask the
more what i call follow-up questions the
more and more interested you appear to
somebody want to be happy build a life
not just the business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel is created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven habits to use
to improve your communication skills
enjoy
habit number two speak with respect with
robin sharma you can say whatever you
want so long as you say it with respect
that's so important i want to
say suggest it to you twice
you can say whatever you want
so long as you say it with respect if
your friend is late for dinner and it's
important to you that they're on time
well if you lash out at them and say why
were you late
you know i'm angry
that's going to put them into attack
mode which is going to cause them to be
defensive but if you say to them
you know johnny or ravi
or
what mary
whatever their name is if you say you
know what thank you so much for joining
me for dinner
before we get started and enjoy this
incredible meal if i may i just like to
share something with deep respect
punctuality is so important to me and
i've been waiting for here for half an
hour and your time is valuable and my
time is valuable and i'd be ever so
grateful if when we get together you
would respect my time just like i want
to respect your time you've set it with
respect look how powerful that is and if
it is a healthy person versus a toxic
person
they're going to appreciate you being so
truthful and you're also going to teach
them the punctuality matters so the
second tactic is you can say whatever
you want to a teammate to an employee to
a customer to a family member so long as
you say it with love and respect habit
number three structure your content with
matt abrahams
structure is critical to success in
communication
structure helps us in two ways
first it helps us to set our audience's
expectations
and second it helps our audience to
remember
i learned this first rule
very early in my life
when i was an undergraduate here at
stanford i was a tour guide
they trained me for 12 weeks a full
academic quarter to be a tour guide the
best thing listen
the best and most important thing they
said to be a good tour guide is never
lose your tour group
[Laughter]
you are a bad tour guide if you lose
your tour group and here on campus they
were afraid of people get lost they
might get hurt
the same thing is true in your
communication
never lose your audience because once
you lose them it's very hard to get them
back
they go to their phones they go to their
friends they go to sleep
we need to keep them with us
setting expectations helps that's why
tour guides always set expectations that
structure helps prepare you so you can
be present and enjoy the tour
structure in your communication does the
same thing
but structure also helps with memory
for you and for your audience it
provides a map and you can't be lost if
you have a map
so allow me to share with you three of
my favorite structures that once you
have your goal you place your content
into
the first structure is a comparison
contrast conclusion structure
you list things in common you list
things that are different and then you
identify your particular
conclusion
another structure that works very well
is the problem solution benefit
structure you start by talking about
what the problem is
you then talk about how you solve it and
ultimately you end with the benefits to
the person listening
now sometimes the problem isn't really a
problem it's really an opportunity so
this could become the opportunity
solution benefit structure as well
now finally
my most favorite structure and i'm the
kind of guy that has a favorite
structure is the what so what now what
structure
in this structure you start by defining
what it is you're talking about a
product a process an idea
you then talk about why it's important
to the people you're talking to that's
the so what
and then the now what are the next steps
what can somebody do with that
information
i like this structure so much because it
not only helps with
presenting
but it's a great way to set up a meeting
agenda it's a good way to structure an
email
you can even give feedback and answer
questions in this structure
i encourage each and every one of you to
try putting your communication into the
structure
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
number four talk about things you know
with gary vaynerchuk my biggest secret
is talk about what you know you're
good at right like talk about stuff you
know you know i try not to answer
questions about foreign policy or
currency or you notice i stay away from
bitcoin or you know i don't talk about
the things i don't know right i can spew
my opinion and at the end of the day
this show and everything else is my
opinion but boy is that grounded in
really strong research and skill and
practitioner dna i feel like my opinion
in business matters because of the
execution i did to get there whereas my
opinion on everything else i have my
opinions on a lot of things but
you know they're not as grounded as much
research they're more intuitive which is
fine take them for what they are you
know what opinions are but i uh
you know i stick to what i know and that
helps me just stream i'm a good
communicator by by dna and
by staying in my comfort zone in my
lanes of expertise and the places where
i actually spend my time honing my craft
it comes off very clean because it's
very natural because it is natural habit
number five elicit your emotions with
brendan burchard the most advanced
communication strategy in the world is
to elicit emotion more
elicit emotion more
to ask about
their feeling so they describe their day
instead of saying oh then what did you
do next
that's like procedural and say it's like
oh how did you feel about that
i uh some of you guys know i was lucky
to
work with and know and um do business
with
one of the persons considered one of the
great interviewers in history uh two
different types of people uh with larry
king is a great friend and mentor and
done work with him and oprah winfrey
great friend and mentor and then work
with her both of them are master
master listeners
something i learned from larry that i'll
never forget that i will never forget
is
i was kind of asking what makes a great
interviewer
and he gave me this example of the
question
one of the first questions he asked mark
zuckerberg so
uh mark
what's it feel like to be
the ceo of facebook
what's it like to be the ceo of facebook
he went right to trying to get to like
what what what does that feel like
that's a big company you know you reach
you know
two billion people now what's that feel
like
see great communicators
are listening
observing
asking about
feelings
emotion
right oprah's magic on her set was she
was able
through her vulnerability and her
openness
for 25 years on television at the top
to
be able to have people feel so
comfortable
with her presence that they would openly
share their feelings well that wouldn't
happen on other shows right you watch
oprah winfrey and then you watch like
you know a news television broadcast
it's completely different
the engagement she had with other people
because she was willing to go into
emotion
you've got to be willing to go into
motion if you're trying to do anything
with people lead them persuade them sell
help serve
emotion has to
bubble up
you need to elicit feeling from people
way more often way more often it's it's
not just hey honey how did school go
today well i went to this class i had
this for lunch this kid was nice this
kid wasn't it's like
how did you feel about that
how did you feel about that
what were you feeling when that was
happening
these types of questions are so basic
and people forget to ask them but that's
what's really advanced because that's
what elicits more what's advanced in
communication strategies what does what
elicits more what else is more but not
just more information more feeling habit
number six be clear with brian tracy my
favorite word in communications is the
word clarity
almost all of our problems in life
become because of lack of clarity we say
things but they don't come out clearly
so
in order to be clear first of all stop
and then think and then proceed slowly
another great word is to rephrase or
repeat something
let's say you say something and somebody
goes huh or it's clear that they didn't
get the message
i speak different languages french
german spanish and i'm busy working on
learning russian and chinese now and one
of the things i learned in languages is
if you say something in your limited
language and they don't seem to
understand it rephrase it and say it
again
and if they don't understand it rephrase
it and say it again until people go
now i understand
so effective communication starts with
you being very clear in your own mind
about what you want to say and then
being very clear
when you say it and then saying it
slowly and patiently and making sure
that the other person hears the message
that you sent
you know you can imagine in
communications that here is you and you
want to communicate with this person and
so you send a message almost like a
message by telephone or by a carrier
pigeon you send a message into the error
in the form of words these words are
then received by the other person who
then interprets the words in their own
mind based on their own thoughts
feelings whether they're paying
attention and so on and then
reformulates or formulates a response
and sends the response back
you then receive the response translate
that into meaning and significance and
then you send it back
between these two responses there's what
are called noise noise can be physical
noise
outside around mechanics trucks and so
on but it can also be internal noise the
person can be hungry or distracted it
can be emotional noise the person can be
unhappy or excited
the person can have other noise in that
they are interpreting what you say in a
different way so if you think about this
communications requires sending the
message and having it received and
checking and then sending the message
back and having it received and then
checking and simply going slowly so it's
better to be sure at every stage of the
transfer of the transaction that people
are sending and receiving with
tremendous clarity and here is my
favorite question of all when somebody
says something that you're not really
sure about say how do you mean
or how do you mean exactly
and they will always expand on what they
just said and make it clearer for you
and easier for you to understand
and to respond effectively and habit
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is really
connect with people with john maxwell
very few people really grab you
emotionally mentally
to the place where they really connect
with you
and i've thought so often about the fact
that we spend so much time we're trying
to communicate to our boss we're trying
to communicate to our family members
you know we're it's so important in our
life and yet nobody's ever really taught
us how do you really connect with people
so that when you're done talking you
realize that some value is going to come
forth out of that process
and so i want to talk to you about it
and i want to read to you and it's in
your notes uh but i want to read to you
uh just a couple of sentences that is in
my book everyone communicates view
connect that kind of sets the the
foundation for what i want to do
if it is true that almost everything we
become and accomplish in life
is with
and through other people
then the ability to connect and create a
rapport with them is the most important
skill
that we can learn
i believe that with all of my heart i
developed this lesson just maybe six
seven weeks ago so let's go with it
there there are just some things i want
to share with you of how i learned to to
connect with people number one here we
go
i understood the value of connecting
with others
and then what's interesting is i
understood the value of connecting it
with others at a very young age
and i don't know whether it's because i
have some communication gifts that i was
given by god and so therefore it was
always kind of apparent to me who
connected and who didn't but i can still
remember being in my third grade class
and then going to my fourth grade class
miss stein was my third grade teacher
miss casey was my fourth grade teacher
and there's a world difference between
those two years
i mean okay one's a little bit higher i
know that
[Music]
but
miss tasty every kid in the class loved
i mean this lady knew how to connect
with her her class miss stein
totally opposite effect and i can still
remember being in the fourth grade and
as a little kid saying why is it that
this teacher everybody likes this
teacher and in my last
year no one liked
that teacher and i can still remember
being in high school you remember this
or maybe in college where you have
several teachers maybe you can select
for a course do you remember in college
how you used to fight to get into
somebody's class
i mean i mean you got five different
teachers teaching the very same course i
mean so i mean the credits the credit
and hello that you've got to pay for it
regardless but how everybody fought to
get in somebody's now why did we all
fight to get into somebody's class and
we all kind of
did everything we could not to get in
someone else's class
same subject same school same tuition
nothing changes except
one prof can connect
one could not
[Music]
i still remember even watching kids on
on at recess
and why was it that some kids had other
kids around them and they were just
absolutely
having a good time together and they
needed to see some kids and they were
just over there by themselves
and i remember look at them and say why
why
why don't those kids connect with other
kids
when i realized i was going to go into
the ministry
i became greatly concerned
because i was used to preachers that
were boring
and i can remember i think god's called
me
to bore people
god's called me to get up and
say things that people can't understand
in such a way that they don't care
and i remember how
great concern to me because i thought
this is not a good thing and i don't
know if i want to be like that because
basically the models that i had pretty
much were those that that weren't really
not effective in their connecting and
communication skills and so at a very
young age even though i didn't
understand how to connect i understood i
mean at a very elementary age i
understood that some people connected
and some people didn't and those that
connected were successful and those that
did not connect were not a successful
period
case dismissed i knew that in elementary
school
and it within me gave me a desire to say
i got to figure this out i don't know
how to do it but i got to figure it out
[Music]
now the second thing i'm going to share
with you on my journey of connecting
was a mistake okay it's the only kind of
negative example but i've got to put it
in there because it was so it was such a
problem for me that i have to pass it on
to you with integrity and authenticity
number two i tried to imitate connectors
that i admired
the few
again my world was the pastor world okay
the few that i knew that were good
i thought i got to become like him and i
can still remember there was a guy named
charlie williams and i'm telling you the
guy looked the guy
was just he he was just great to look at
he's a good-looking guy and i mean he
was massive and he kind of looked like
he was a bodybuilder and i mean you know
i i don't know if he was a great
preacher but everybody just thought he
was great just to look at him okay
and he was an orator
major orator
and i thought okay i've got to learn how
to do oratory
and so as a very young pastor i tried
that
and i mean i memorized i mean i
memorized by the our phrases
so that i could say things like i've
been to vermont where i've seen the
daffodils tucked down by the green
hillside i just talked about and i use
this phraseology and i was so bad at it
i would i would mess it up every time
and i'd have rose bushes tucking down
azaleas or something and i was just i
was not it was not my gift and i
remember i would try it and try and i
would retry it and i would memorize i
remember there was a guy named lawrence
hicks one time who preached a message
great orator there must be a heaven
somewhere and he said it with he
preached it with a southern draw i even
got the southern drawl down
and i preached this there must be a
heaven somewhere and it and and i i you
know i
when i went to my second church they to
get into churches you had what they
called trial sermons you had to go do a
sermon and the people sit there and they
kind of decide if they want you to be
the pastor based upon your sermon now
that's a stupid way to pick a pastor but
you got to understand i grew up with a
bunch of wonderful stupid people so i
mean it really works in that in that in
that context
and i remember i went to that church and
i really wanted to go to that church so
i preached there must be a heaven
somewhere and i mean they thought i was
an orator now what they didn't
understand was the only message i had
you understand that
you know next week they're going i'm
going to be preaching there must be a
sermon somewhere you know what i'm
saying i haven't been able to find it
but i'm sure it's somewhere here but i
tried i tried to i made a huge mistake i
tried to imitate people
that i admired or people that i thought
could communicate there was another guy
that was a that memorized scripture
never took his bible just get up kind of
lean on the on the pulpit and he just
quoted scripture so i thought man i'll
memorize scriptures i remember i
memorized first john second john you
noticed i started with small books i
didn't want to go with anything huge and
big and i would get up and i would try
to quote scripture and i and and i would
mess it up every time and i again i saw
it it wasn't who i was
now in your notes i i i said something i
put in there something that i love by
joyce meyer god will help you
be all you can be
but it'll never help you be somebody
else
i really believe that
i had to in my communication and
connecting
come to grips with the fact
there were a lot of gifts in connecting
communication that i did not possess and
i was never going to be like those
people
so number three
i determined to be myself
and to build on my strengths
woody allen one time said my only regret
in life is that i'm not somebody else
and i think we've all felt that doris
morton one time said until you make
peace with who you are you'll never be
content
with what you have
as a young kid trying to communicate and
connect still looking to find my way
this took me years this is not something
i got quickly
my question went from
what do they have that i want in other
words
what are they how do they communicate so
i can learn how to do it that way to
what do i have the people will want
and i just totally changed the question
what's within me
what do i have what gifts do i have
abilities i have to help me to connect
that that people would want and i'll
tell you what i did this is the most fun
part maybe of the lesson for me because
i can still remember about 21 22 still
very young in my communication
i remember it it dawned on me one day no
one taught me this but one day in my
searching to learn how to connect it
dawned on me that if i was going to
connect i had to find out what was
within me the strengths that was within
me and somehow use that into my
connecting repertoire
and i slowly began over the next couple
three years to find out
what is innately john maxwell that
allows me to have authenticity when i
communicate and connect
in such a way that it touches people's
lives
communication is one of the most
important skills that entrepreneurs need
to have and i think a lot of businesses
fail because the entrepreneur cannot
communicate well and if they even are
sharing their ideas they are not
convincing enough and so a lot of great
ideas die
you could have the next greatest idea
that can change the world it's sitting
up here
but because you can't articulate it
because you can't share it because you
can't communicate it well and because
you're not convincing enough to the
people around you it will never take off
the idea will die within you and i hate
that
i hate that because building a business
getting the thing that's out here out
into the world is greater than one
person no matter how much of a genius
you are
to build a business you need a team you
need a team of people to help you go far
and you also need to convince the media
and customers and partners and suppliers
that what you have
is amazing
if you are the only one who thinks that
your idea is amazing and you can't
communicate or convince anybody else of
that then you're done then that idea
dies within you and i think
unfortunately that's a lot of
entrepreneurs so jordan has three of his
tips i'm gonna give you three of mine on
how to be a convincing communicator step
number one is have a powerful opinion
you have an opinion what is it that you
are trying to say make it mean something
to yourself and to me and make that the
first sentence of every piece of content
that you make if you're doing a video
that's your first sentence you do an
instagram post put it in there you do a
linkedin post an email a newsletter like
put it in there you lead with your
powerful opinion on what is wrong with
the world or what your viewpoint on xyz
topic is make it mean something to me
make me care so if i'm talking about
communication how important it is for
entrepreneurs a powerful opinion would
be something like you need to learn how
to communicate in your business or you
will never get that idea that's in your
head out into the world and your idea
will die inside you that's an opinion
where lots of people might say something
like so if you want to learn how to
build a successful business and maybe
take your idea to the next level i think
maybe you should focus on trying to
improve how you speak and communicate
like it's so long it has lots of filler
words you use words like maybe and
potentially and someday and one day and
i wish and we instead of i like
affirmative stop worrying about what
people's reactions are going to be and
speak your truth always lead with a
powerful opinion tip number two is
emotional commitment
this is where a lot of entrepreneurs
really fall down you've got your
powerful opinion you know what you stand
for you know what you're trying to
communicate
but when you get in front of a camera or
when you get down to writing it doesn't
sway people it's not emotional enough
you could be saying all the best words
when you get in front of a camera to
make a video but because you are
talking in a very
boring very
non-exciting manner and because you're
so worried about saying the perfect
words that you are memorizing something
or you are looking at your script or
trying to read from a teleprompter
nobody is going to care or listen to you
you need to have emotional commitment
you need to feel the thing and how
important it is while you are saying it
for me
i'm envisioning all of you i'm
envisioning all the entrepreneurs that
i've worked with who have these amazing
ideas and they never get them out
because they can't communicate and even
though i'm sitting here in an office by
myself and there's nobody around to
actually connect with i'm just talking
to a camera
i'm trying to channel you i'm trying to
channel all the people that i've
connected with and seen and i want to
make sure that your business does well
and communicating is so important as
part of that which is why i'm doing this
video and hopefully the care the love
the energy comes through
in the content that i make and so sales
and convincing people not enough against
what they want but in a positive way
like this is something you guys can get
together on is about the energy transfer
you are not just selling a concept or an
idea you are transferring energy
whoever is more confident wins whoever
is more convincing wins and it's usually
from whoever believes in their thing
more if you absolutely believe in your
thing and that this is right and it's
for them and they need to do this thing
because it's in their best interest not
because they're just trying to sell
something down their throat but you
really really really really care
and if they feel that care as opposed to
just words that you're saying
that's how you bring them on board
it's great to have the best words but
more important is the emotional
commitment that you have behind them
so the best test with any of this is
watch back some of your content like
watch back your videos read your
newsletters see the copy on your website
look at the story that you wrote about
yourself and why you started this
business does it get you excited it's
like boom boom boom boom boom like yes
that's right that's why i do this thing
or do you watch it and you get bored
if you get bored and it doesn't get your
heart beating then do it again do it
again and do it again and do it again
and do it again you will be one of your
best critics you will be one of your
harshest critics and so being able to
look over your content and get to the
point where you say wow
yeah
i'm really proud of that
that's when you start to win and tip
number three is raise the stakes just
make it more important if you want to
move people
so often we're focused just on the
tactics the strategies here's the five
things that you need to do and people
say yeah yeah yeah great i love those
the five things awesome they write them
down and then they never do anything
about it
you need to raise the stakes you have to
make it more important you have to make
me feel the pressure that if i don't do
this thing that you want me to do
terrible things will happen right so if
i talk about how important communication
is
me just saying
communication is really important as an
entrepreneur here are the three ways to
do it it's not as powerful as
communication is one of the most
important skills that entrepreneurs need
to have because if you don't learn how
to communicate your idea and get it out
there that idea will die inside you and
your mission will never be realized
and listen that paints a dark picture
that's going to an extreme and the idea
is not to have hyperbole and make things
bigger than they are
but that's a real case for tons of
entrepreneurs that if they do not learn
how to communicate properly their ideas
will never get out there and their idea
will die inside them and so your goal if
you want to move people is to make them
realize how big this thing is for them
if they don't take action you're the
expert you know where the road is going
you see their future if they continue
down that path
they don't see that future they don't
understand it it's your job to help them
see
where this current path of action is
going to lead them
and if they make the tweak they make the
change to take your recommendations
where it could go raise the stakes make
it more important make them feel that
it's more important and it actually
starts with you feeling that this
message is insanely important rapport is
power
earlier today we said anything you want
to achieve
anything you want to learn master
experience there's somebody out there
who has a life experience the
understanding the network
the capital
the thing you need to be able to achieve
it
but they're not going to give you what
they want or they're not going to do
what you want rather a need until you
first give them what they want and need
and you're not even going to find out
what they want need until you first
get in a relationship of rapport if you
don't do that you're never gonna learn
anything
rapport's power what is a relationship
of rapport rapport means total
responsiveness between people
when someone is totally responding to
you and you're totally responding to
them you're in rapport there's that
connection it's that spark that happens
in certain communications or
relationships
now everybody wants to create rapport
have it but most people only get rapport
with people who are like whom
themselves and they lose with everybody
else which means you got a very limited
world
so we want to take it to a different
level so let's say for example if i said
to you right now guys i want you to go
out to a local restaurant or bar and i
want you to meet somebody and i want you
to develop rapport with them a
connection with them how many feel like
you do that no problem say i
and if you're not raising your hand
you're probably selling yourself short
of course you could how would you do it
though you'd walk in this restaurant a
bar you meet somebody and you engage
them in conversation by asking a few
what
questions now is it possible to ask a
few questions and have a conversation go
and just die is that possible yes or no
so questions don't create rapport
questions are a tool we use to dig for
something what are you digging for when
you're asking these questions you're
trying to find something in what
that's right so write your notes rapport
is created by a feeling of commonality
rapport is created
by a feeling
of commonality
rapport is created by feeling of
commonality when people we feel like we
have something in common with someone
there's a spark
now here's the problem if rapport is
created by a feeling of commonality most
people try to get rapport by using words
but you've already learned something
what percentage of our communication
skills are words what percentage
seven percent which means you're leaving
out 93 of your skills
which is why most people don't get
rapport with a large number of people
you know what do you do walk in a
restaurant a bar and go hi what's your
name where are you from why are you here
the person says my name is habib i'm
from iraq i'm a terrorist i'm here to
kill people and you go
amazing me too
no
see words don't always work do they
but there is something that always works
to get rapport and it's something called
matching
and mirroring
matching and mirroring
now matching and mirroring came about 35
years ago
when it's we've all done matching and
bearing our whole lives but the person
who pointed out was milton erickson dr
erickson was a genius
what he did was he was a medical doctor
but he also
was a psychologist and a hypnotherapist
probably the best that ever lived
and people will come to see him who try
to change everything anywhere else in
their life nothing at work they see him
for one session he'd handle it
and the reason is because he understood
something he understood that you have
both a conscious mind and a subconscious
mind
and he knew the subconscious is more
powerful it's the part that makes your
heart beat a hundred thousand times a
day without having to think about so he
knew if he could influence your
subconscious mind he could change
anything and that's what he did but
here's how he did it he had polio
so he was in a wheelchair so he spent an
enormous amount of time studying people
and he began to notice something about
human beings that when human beings got
together if they got in rapport a
relationship of responsiveness they
became like each other in a variety of
ways what he called they mirrored each
other
now i've taught this for 25 years i'm
sure you've heard of it i've written in
my books and it's been taught in a
variety of other areas now but it's one
thing to know it intellectually or to
understand it's another thing to know it
when you're doing it that's what i want
to get you to do tonight so you have a
real experience of it that you won't
forget
but here's the basis of it people like
people who are like whom
themselves and people don't like people
who are not like themselves to be more
specific write this down people like
people who are like themselves or
who are like how they would like to be
people like people who are like
themselves
or
are how they would like to be
people like people are like themselves
or how they would like to be so question
i'd like you to think of someone you
really really like a lot
and then if you would
raise your hand this person is either
like you or they're like how you want to
be if that's true raise your hand say
i of course that's why you like them now
think of someone you don't like
i'm sure you like everyone but if you
once were an unspiritual person and felt
these feelings
some of you don't like
raise your hand if they're not like you
or they're not like how you want to be
if that's true raise your hand say i
and that's the opposite people don't
like people who are not like them or are
not like how they want to be that's the
bottom line of it so this concept
erickson noticed he used it in the
following way watch me if you came to
see dr erickson instead of talking to
you intellectually and trying to get
through to you he'd go right to the
jugular by getting your nervous system
connected to him getting rapport so if
you came to him and you said
dr erickson um
i don't know this is a waste of time
i've i've tried everything and
i don't know i think i should just go
he would do this he'd go
i'm sure it looks that way on the
surface but
you haven't tried this so
you haven't tried everything and
i think he should stay
and the person would go huh
something about this guy i like
you know he's not over the top you know
what i mean he's like really real
there's just something about him that
feels down home and real to me
right if you came to see him he said dr
erickson i've tried everything it's a
waste of my time i'm out of here he'd
say you sit out you haven't tried
everything you've not done this before
you're staying right here guy goes hey i
like this guy it's got some spunk kick
ass maybe he could do something
see he became like the people he was
communicating with and what it was is
whatever they put out he sent the same
message back like bio feedback and then
trained them to him so that when he then
told their unconscious what to do their
brain just did it that was his power i'd
like to suggest that there are four
really powerful cornerstones foundations
that we can stand on if we want our
speech to be powerful and to make change
in the world
fortunately these things spell a word
the word is hail and it has a great
definition as well i'm not talking about
the stuff that falls from the sky and
hits you on the head i'm talking about
this definition to greet or acclaim
enthusiastically which is i think how
our words will be received if we stand
on these four things so what do they
stand for
see if you can guess
the h
honesty of course
being true in what you say being
straight and clear
the a is authenticity
just being yourself a friend of mine
described it as standing in your own
truth which i think is a lovely way to
put it the i is integrity
being your word actually doing what you
say and being somebody people can trust
and the l
is love
i don't mean romantic love
but i do mean wishing people well
for two reasons first of all i think
absolute honesty may not be what we want
i mean my goodness you look ugly this
morning
perhaps
that's not necessary
tempered with love of course honesty is
a great thing but also if you're really
wishing somebody well it's very hard to
judge them at the same time i'm not even
sure you can do those two things
simultaneously
so hail
also now that's what you say and it's
like the old song it is what you say
it's also the way that you say it you
have an amazing toolbox this instrument
is incredible and yet this is a toolbox
that very few people have ever opened
i'd like to have a little rummage in
there with you now just pull a few tools
out that you might like to take away and
play with which will increase the power
of your speaking
register for example
now falsetto register may not be very
useful most of the time
but there's a register in between i'm
not going to get very technical about
this for any of you who are voice
coaches you can locate your voice
however so if i talk up here in my nose
you can hear the difference if i go down
here in my throat which is where most of
us speak from most of the time
but if you want weight you need to go
down here to the chest you hear the
difference
we vote for politicians with lower
voices it's true
because we associate depth with power
and with authority
that's register
and we have tamba it's the the way your
voice feels again the research shows
that we prefer voices which are rich
smooth warm
like hot chocolate
well if that's not you
that's not the end of the world because
you can train go get a voice coach and
there are amazing things you can do with
breathing with posture and with
exercises to improve the timbre of your
voice
then prozadi i love prosidy this is the
sing-song the meta language that we use
in order to impart meaning it's root one
for meaning in conversation people who
speak all on one note are really quite
hard to listen to if they don't have any
prosidy at all
that's where the word monotonic comes
from or monotonous monotone
also we have repetitive prosidy now
coming in
where every sentence ends as if it were
a question when it's actually not a
question it's a statement
and if you repeat that one over and over
it's actually restricting your ability
to communicate through prosidy which i
think is a shame
so let's try and break that habit
pace i can get very very excited by
saying something really really quickly
or i can slow right down to emphasize
and at the end of that of course is our
old friend silence
there's nothing wrong with a bit of
silence in a talk is there
we don't have to fill it with um's and
ours
can be very powerful
of course pitch often goes along with
pace to indicate arousal but you can do
it just with pitch where did you leave
my keys
where did you leave my keys
it's a slightly different
meaning in those two deliveries
and finally volume
i can get really excited
by reusing volume sorry about that if i
startled anybody
or i can have you really pay attention
by getting very quiet
some people broadcast the whole time try
not to do that that's called sodcasting
imposing your sound on people around you
carelessly and inconsiderately not nice
of course where this all comes into play
most of all is when you've got something
really important to do it might be
standing on a stage like this and giving
a talk to people it might be proposing
marriage
asking for a raise
a wedding speech whatever it is if it's
really important you owe it to yourself
to look at this toolbox and the engine
that it's going to work on and no engine
works well without being warmed up
warm up your voice
one of the things i observe is simply
this a lot of people are very careless
with their language
and so you know there's a huge shift you
can either be a victim or you can be a
leader but you can't be both and if you
look at someone who is a victim
a lot of their victimhood
comes down to the words they use
i mean the words you use either lift up
your energy the words you use either
make you more creative the words you use
either allow you to do world-class
things or the words you use deny your
talents the words you use could reduce
your energy the words you use could hurt
your leadership so you have a choice
every day at work and at home and out on
the streets with strangers you can
develop a victim vocabulary or the
language of leadership and in this
mastery session i want to walk you
through some of my insights on those
well words are powerful
i mean words have destroyed nations i
mean think about the great dictators
they're words of hatred
they're words of toxicity
they're words of breakdown
caused the people around them to do
sometimes
incredibly terrifying acts
and then you look at people like nelson
mandela or martin luther king jr or a
mother teresa you look at the great
business builders you look at
humanitarians you look at a lot of the
great artists and they were so careful
with their words and their words lifted
people up and that's really what great
leaders do they use the language of
leadership
you look at a victim and they say things
like
this is a problem i've got a problem
right here or i'm really scared about
this or i hate that client or i hate
this work or i'm sick of
this day or i'm exhausted or i don't
like that or she never likes me it's
literally the language of toxicity
and the words you use really
are like a context or a framework or a
stained glass window on the way you see
the world i mean here's a game-changing
insight you see the world not as it is
you see the world as you are
you see the world through a lens and
your language forms that lens of belief
i mean your lens of belief and your
personal filter on reality
is not really a true filter on reality
it's just the
filter on reality that has formed as a
result of all the words you've picked up
from the moment you were born
so when you were a little baby your mom
and your dad used the language that they
were taught when they were kids
to use
and if they use the language of
victimitis and if they use the language
of victimhood like well you know
you can't do this i hate this i'm tired
of this money doesn't grow on trees
be ordinary if you're successful you'll
be hated all that messaging that we pick
up from our parents and the media and
the world around us and our peers the
little kids that we used to play with in
the playground or the friends that we
had as teenagers
that will either lift us up or tear us
down so i guess what i'm trying to say
and hopefully i'm making the point
clearly for you but we see the world
through this personal filter and a lot
of this personal filter that drives our
performance and our behavior is really
constructed from the words that we've
picked up and then the words we are
taught to use and so the right angle
turn for you
to create exponential energy mindset
productivity creativity results in the
world results in your life comes down to
in part a really intelligent use of your
words and like i said at the beginning
of this mastery session
most people are really unconscious about
their words
and that's why most people are not
getting
rare air results
so what are some of the words i
encourage you to shift from
well don't talk about what you hate to
do talk about what you love to do don't
talk about problems talk about
opportunities don't talk about what
makes you tired talk about what makes
you inspired
don't talk about your past talk about
your future
don't talk about what broke your your
heart talk about what opened your heart
don't talk about what dispirits you talk
about what you
are fueled by
don't talk about the things within your
life that are not working talk about the
things in your life that are working
don't talk about
your pain talk about your pleasure
and you know if i if i were sitting with
you right now coaching you i mean i am
coaching you and what i would encourage
you to do as soon as i finish this
mastery session is pull out your journal
and if you're not journaling please
start journaling because journaling is a
ritual you want to install into your
days
joan didion said this
i don't know what i think until i write
it down
think about that i don't know what i
think until i write it down
and so in your journal after this
mastery session
pull out a fresh page
and draw a line down the center of the
page and write about
the language of victimhood and the
language of leadership leadership and
start to write down
all the words you use and the sentences
you employ that really are speaking that
are really victims speak
and then in the other column i want to
start writing down the language of
leadership the language that as of today
you will be committed
to using so that you start to use the
language of someone who's world class
and i've given you some examples but
doing that exercise will make it really
clear and as you know clarity breeds
mastery
bottom line is this you are built to be
a leader you are not constructed to be a
victim and once you get your words right
you are going to start noticing daily
shifts in your energy your focus your
momentum your confidence and your output
and when you start getting those words
right you start lifting your
professional life your personal life to
a whole new level of wow and guess what
that is what you are meant to do a bit
of a warning
what i'm about to tell you to do is
terrifying and most of us spend our
entire lives trying to avoid it but
like a pap smear it's over fast
and it really works
i just did it did you catch it if not
and you missed it here it goes again
awkward
that was a live demonstration of the
three second iap the intentional awkward
pause
oh my god this is so awkward now why on
god's green earth would you ever want to
do that i'll tell you because being a
really really good listener is one of
the most underrated secrets to success
it's crucial if you want to be more
charismatic more persuasive and a better
negotiator plus
really listening to someone and having
them feel truly heard is one of the
biggest gifts you could ever give the
problem is most of us suck at listening
and we don't even know it we're always
interrupting others with our brilliant
ideas and our feedback and most often
it's the way oh my god that is so true
i'm always interrupting people
as i was saying it's often the way that
we suck the most
now i'm probably one of the worst
offenders out there but i am
consistently working on this and i have
to say the iap is a lifesaver not so
long ago i used it with my stepson zane
and had an unbelievable result so zayn
was home on christmas break from college
and he invited me to go for cappuccinos
so a little back story here in the 10
years plus that we've been in each
other's lives he had never really asked
me for life advice so we get to this
place cafe minerva and we're hanging out
and zane starts to tell me all about his
life and what he might want to do with
it he's very very involved with music
he's involved in acting and all these
creative things so basically he's asking
me for the kind of advice that i give
for a living so you could imagine every
single part of me just wanted to jump in
and tell him what to do and tell him
what i think and yada yada but i
practiced the iap and i just sat there
and i zipped it now every time i did
this and i just shut up it was amazing
because he would just reveal more and
more insights he'd find new things to
talk about he'd find his own insights
that were way better than anything i
could have told him it was really really
amazing now i have to be honest my body
was literally uncomfortable being silent
so every time he would come to an end of
a sentence i would sit
and see if there was more and it was
absolutely awesome by the end of three
hours we had the most beautiful
conversation and we left that cafe
feeling more connected and more intimate
than i think we've ever felt so just a
little story to show that it really
really works i'm incredibly nervous to
talk in front of you because you've got
to be one of the most formidable people
that i've ever
heard of or ever listened to or ever
seen so
my question is
again you're one of the best
communicators that i've ever listened to
if i could be
half as good at you or at communicating
as you are
i would be set how can i teach myself to
do that
practice
you know really like
well there's a couple of things is
it helps to read a lot
it really helps to write
so if you want to make yourself
articulate
which is a very good idea
then
not only should you read but you should
write down what you think
and if you can do that a little bit
every day
15 minutes
maybe you could steal 15 minutes and do
it every day
but if you do that for 10 years you
really straighten out your thinking
if you're going to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about you know so if you this is
often difficult for beginning lectures
at university because they'll do a
lecture on a topic but they only know as
much as they're saying in the lecture
and they get kind of stuck to their
notes because of it but you want to know
ten times as much as you are saying in
the lecture and then you can
specify a stepping path through it and
elaborate with the other things that you
know but to do that you have to do a lot
of reading but you also have to do a lot
of reading because that's where the
synthesize that's where the synthesizing
comes
so that's on the input side and then on
the output side
well there's some tricks techniques
let's say is like if you're speaking in
front of a group you are not delivering
a talk to a group
that's not what you're doing the talk
isn't a package thing that you present
to a group there isn't a group
there's a bunch of individuals
and you talk to them so when i talk to a
group i always talk to people one at a
time and that makes it easier too
because you know how to talk to a person
it's like can you talk to a thousand
people well probably not because it's
too intimidating but there isn't a
thousand people there
there's
a thousand individuals and so you just
look at an individual and you say
something and you can tell
if they're engaged
they look confused or they look
interested or they look angry or they
look bored or maybe they're asleep in
which case you look at someone else
and they they give you feedback about
how you're doing and so
one thing is to to have something to say
yeah
but the next thing is pay attention to
who you're talking to
because unless you're
very badly socialized and that seems
unlikely in your case because you know
you present yourself at least moderately
well you know
and
well i mean i don't know you very well
but in first but on first sight
you know you're doing fine so the
probability that if you pay attention to
the individuals that you're talking to
that your natural
wealth of of social skill will manifest
itself is extremely high
and so you don't deliver a talk to an
audience that's a really bad way of
thinking about it you're actually
engaged in a conversation with an
audience even if they're not
talking they're nodding and
shifting position and you know looking
like this or
and you can you can pull all that in and
and and use it to govern
the level at which you're addressing the
entire audience
so the last thing i would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well i
could buttress that to some degree
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent
in everything you do than to learn how
to communicate i don't care if you're
going to be a carpenter i mean being a
carpenter by the way is very difficult
especially if you're a good carpenter
but if you're good at communicating as a
carpenter you're like 10 times better as
a carpenter
so
the and this is something that the
liberal arts colleges i think
i don't know if they've forgotten it but
they don't do a very good job of
marketing it's like what's the use of a
bachelor's degree in bachelor of arts
it's like well
you can think
you can write
you can speak
you've read something
it's like
the economic value of that is
incalculable the people that i've
watched in my life who've been
spectacularly successful are
they have skills
clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful
well that's kind of like the definition
of success in life right you negotiate
and you're sick it doesn't mean you win
because if you're a good negotiator if
you're really good negotiator everybody
walks away from the negotiation thrilled
and so then people line up to do things
with you
so and that's all that's all dependent
on your ability to communicate so
practice
enthusiasm i mean look at the video of
me coming out on stage watching me
interact with the audience so watch me
on any of my youtube videos watch listen
to my podcast hpx podcast it's like
everything that i believe about hpx
which stands for the high performance
experience
is about the enthusiasm and zest we must
have for life or that we must generate
and create and so i'm just enthusiastic
on stage even if i'm scared even i'm
worried even i'm concerned and i mean
certainly walking out in front of
thousands of people wasn't my original
jam i mean i i was that person who was
not good at that did not have skill now
and did not want to do that
but the reason that i became a good
communicator and challenged myself to
become a good communicator was because i
realized if i couldn't communicate well
i couldn't make a good difference
if you don't teach yourself train
yourself put yourself in those
situations where you become a better
speaker a better communicator a better
leader then how are you ever going to
change the world how are you ever going
to do something that you feel is like
significant and important so i train
myself to do that so i make sure that
i'm enthusiastic for my topic and my
mission and my purpose when i go out on
that stage
even if inside
i feel anxiety i feel like i don't know
if i'm gonna do a good job
those things listen when your fear
becomes secondary to your enthusiasm
for your purpose
that's when everything changes that was
a life truth i can say to you continue
to do what you're doing and working on
yourself and working in your mindset and
your presentation power because once you
open your mouth as he said
the world
will now know who you are your ability
and write this down to tell your story
is key
it's major
and how you present yourself 101. why is
that important mr brown because when you
meet someone
and you want to do business with them
people are asking three questions
one-on-one small groups of large groups
they're asking who are you
what do you have
and why should i care
that's what they're asking
because in the business where you are
trust is important am i correct
confidence is important am i correct
it's a lot of skepticism around the
industry because of things that have
happened a major investment that people
have to make am i correct
so now they're looking at you who are
you
and so your ability to tell your story
who are you what do you have your
ability to communicate that in a way
that will connect with people in a way
that will expand their minds in a way
that will touch their heart in a way
that will cause them to say this is the
person that i want to put my trust in
this is a person that i believe
and this major decision that our family
is about to make now
that we should go with how many of you
know that's real raise your hands please
my first time i talked i literally went
up and blanked out like i literally
could not think i could not see the card
how i fixed it speaking was over time
but i'll give you a couple of key things
on speaking for everybody one i had to i
had to figure out you know what someone
said because you love baseball you don't
stutter when you talk about baseball you
don't get insecure i go well i love that
and i believe in it they're like oh you
don't you know you talk about your kids
you're great i thought oh there's a
correlation here between me actually
saying what i believe and what i'm
passionate about and my ability to
communicate it and so that now my first
layer is always i must be passionate
about it and i must believe it and i'm
never doing an impression of another
person so i always come from a place of
saying what i really believe because you
can't transfer to somebody that which
you don't experience yourself i can give
you passion i can give you energy i can
give you my belief if i'm experiencing
it
big key is a speaker i'll give everybody
stop trying to convince everybody of
what you're saying
that's not the threshold of being a good
communicator people do not need to
believe what you're saying they need to
believe you believe what you're saying
and as long as they believe you believe
what you're saying you're an effective
speaker i stopped trying to get people
to believe me there's a neediness
there's a salesmanship to that i stopped
that it's a subtle difference i just
want you to believe i believe it that's
influence influences you believe i
believe it so i was um taking off my um
man thong and um um
and i was like oh my god and you were
like oh my god he has a wife like yo dog
i'm so pissed right now you'll never
believe what happened i was over there
ordering the delicious ass mcrib
sandwich you know what i'm saying and
they forgot the mother freaking pickle
you know what i'm saying yes i do know
what you're saying that the mcrib
sandwich is a culinary mystery meat that
needs pickle to enhance its
deliciousness i also know that using
filler words makes you sound unconfident
unsure of yourself unprofessional and
dare i say dumb as a stump so what about
you
do you use filler words and if so what
is it if you're not sure ask your
friends or family because if you don't
know i'm sure they will because that's
exactly how i found out that i use the
word um all the time tracy one day about
six years ago came up to me was like you
say um all the time i was like i do
i told her to start pointing it out
every time she noticed or heard me use
the word um she would say um
and that was my cue to start paying
attention but something remarkable
happened after a little while of being
ultra aware of myself i would actually
start correcting myself when i'd say i
might be like uh um and it was really
awkward and uncomfortable when i was
having a conversation with somebody else
and eventually i stopped it took hard
work being hyper aware of what you're
saying and a little bit paranoid but
eventually i kicked it and so can you
and a great tip i would give to you is
when you're talking and you feel it
coming on just
pause and pick up where you left off and
eventually you will be able to kick the
filler word habit rarely are we instant
experts you may have a particular gift
or
affinity towards something but you still
get better um
you know
people would pay me high compliments
when i started speaking and then people
who've seen me a year or two later say
that i'm even better and i feel it why
is that
because you you learn more you know i i
think that hubris is dangerous i think
to think that you're an expert in
anything is a is a foolish
pursuit um you're never you're never as
good as you could be there's always room
for improvement there's always room to
get better um you don't that doesn't
mean you have to listen to all the
advice um just you know not necessarily
does everybody know best but but to
believe that you can be better and to
believe that you can offer more um is a
constant pursuit um you know i used to
think being a public speaker meant being
poised and presenting in a way that was
compelling and speaking at the right
pace and that's that's a part of it
um but but i um have been taking more
risks lately doing things that are
very unstructured and very uncomfortable
and i will now do like if i have an hour
to speak i'd rather speak for 20 minutes
and do 40 minutes worth of questions and
who knows how that's gonna go and that
to me is the best and so i'm a better
speaker because now i'm way more open to
the unknown where a few years ago that
that would have scared me
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some great advice for how to
communicate effectively check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there it's evan my one word is
believe and i believe that you have a
special ability to create something
amazing that can change the planet so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn how to communicate
effectively